hey i'm ryan and i'm zach and we're here
with a monday morning review with the
side of spoilers for Veronica Mars the
movie yep now just opening I was a huge
fan of the show did you like this is a
huge fan of the show favorite showdown
in high school it's an amazing show you
should definitely check it out um full
disclosure I love the movie yep
absolutely also full disclosure if you
didn't see the show I think that you
will enjoy the movie but there is so
much fan service which is great this
movie made my heart happy um there's so
much fan service though I'd say if you
haven't seen the show and you go see the
movie you're missing seventy percent of
the joke references one thing that they
were able to do which you said with fan
service was kind of give some kind of
closure to the characters because we did
see the show go off the air in the
middle of the third season so we never
got that the time that has passed in
real life has elapsed in the movie yep
between the show and now and veronica
has kind of gotten her life together
she's in New York she's waiting for a
great job she's with his the nice guy
who finally in this movie gets a moment
of like standing up Logan her old flame
is accused of murder and she returns to
Neptune to prove his innocence and we're
off and running for fans of the
relationship you you get the joy and
seen them on screen together again and I
mean dick Casablancas I mean that's
that's my favorite go-to character for
what yes Ryan Hansen is brilliant you
mentioned seeing them on screen together
part of me the most joy to be had out of
this movie is that you finally you get
to see all these pedia together again um
namely I mean Veronica and Logan is a
huge thing but Veronica and Keith Mars
her father which is kind of the dynamic
and relationship that stayed throughout
the show yeah most beautifully um
they're both brilliant that was the
biggest thing for me it was good to see
that they didn't miss a beat that's very
true this movie feels really organic
nothing about it feels forced it
essentially feels like a really long
episode of the show um so if you're
looking for like the world to open up a
ton it doesn't but if you're looking for
a really good long episode of Veronica
it's great almost every character
returns and as you can even get back to
Neptune like the the owners like that
that was kind of cool to see the bar
yeah for sure and continuation there a
ton of cameos from people who were up
may have appeared on the show who since
then have become very famous yeah that
returned back like max Greenfield is in
one scene Justin Long is in it for like
a shot he's like three lime um Dax
Shepard yeah actually glue who wasn't on
the show but it's so funny and let's
just say the mystery is really engaging
yea the rioting stop nosh I mean Rob
Thomas really knows how to write
Veronica Mars yeah so I mean again if
you're a fan of the show you've already
seen the movie I'm sure that you loved
it I can't imagine a better movie of
Veronica Mars for this I suggest
watching the entire series and then
going to see the movie absolutely and
for people who haven't watched the
series the first five minutes they will
try and catch you up on it but nothing
we do it yeah I don't nothing to replace
more years it's just brilliant some so
obviously Zack and I are huge fans yes
movie but we want to know what do you
think of the movie comment below let us
know if you loved it or if you hated it
and if you hated it we want to hear ya
we want to hear it but we're not going
to respect that opinion at all um so
until next time I'm Ryan and object
thank you for watching
you